... Hallo, schön, dass ihr da seid. Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu dieser neuen Ausgabe von Dibu, das Podcast UFO. Ich fand es natürlich sehr, mit diesen wunderbaren Klängen in die Folge geführt worden zu sein, von Leonie. Vielen, vielen Dank für das Intro, fantastisch, freut uns sehr. Natürlich den kulturellen Anstrich, den wir seit einigen Folgen vermissen lassen, muss man auch mal ehrlich sagen. Aber wir haben schon, muss man sagen, eher extremistische Intros, weil es schwankt immer nur zwischen entweder fullblown, 100% Dreisat oder 100% Gangster-Rap, wo unsere Mütter beleidigt werden, wo wir beleidigt werden, wo wir uns vorher auch immer die Augen gucken müssen und uns angucken müssen und sagen, ist es okay, wenn wir dieses Intro nehmen, weil wir so hart beleidigt werden. Das heißt, die Mitte wäre auch immer einfach nur spannend. Nicht, dass es sollte oder dass die anderen Intros schlecht waren, aber... Ja, wir hatten ja einmal die Einsendung von diesem, wie hieß er, Cat Stevens, Neil Young-Typen. Bob Dylan war es. Bob Dylan, sorry, Bob Dylan. Das war, glaube ich, eine Chance für einen Mittel-Mainstream-Modus, aber da kam leider nichts rum. Aber es hat sich eine Person tatsächlich gefunden, ein anderer Neil-Young-Affizionado, der jetzt einen Artikel schreiben kann für das offizielle Neil-Young-Magazin. Nein. Das aber erst in ein paar Monaten rauskommt, weil so viel gibt es nicht zu berichten, der Mann ist tot. Tut mir leid, es ist heute, dass ihr es so erfahren musstet, aber es ist hinüber. Ich muss ganz kurz ein Disclaimer machen, bevor wir jetzt in die gängige, wöchentliche Witzelei einsteigen. Und zwar, ich habe, bevor ich hierher gekommen bin, habe ich gestaubsaugt. Ich bin schwerst stauballergisch, das heißt, ich bin ein Ticken der Zeitbombe, wann es losgeht, wann wieder das Niezorchester beginnt und ich hier einfach alles vollrotze. Bei den kleiner werdenden Augen sagen wir, dass es schon losgegangen ist. Also der Prozess ist im Gange. Genau, er ist im Gange, er lässt sich nicht mehr aufhalten. Es ist jetzt wirklich nur eine Frage der Zeit. Ihr könnt gerne ein bisschen rumskippen. Ich glaube, man kann das an der Soundcloud ganz gut erkennen, wo viel geniisst wird. Nein, das heißt nicht Soundcloud. Echt jetzt? Ich dachte immer, das heißt Soundcloud, also wenn man diese Audiospur so die Waveform vor sich hat. Aber ja, das nur als kurzer Disclaimer.
Da muss ich auch meinen Disclaimer raushauen. Ich war gerade im Krankenhaus, Blut abgenommen, aber nicht so ein bisschen Blut, sondern halt ich war da für zwei Stunden und jede halbe Stunde wurden so drei Kanülen genommen. Ich habe keinen Blut mehr mit dem Körper. Die hat gesagt, machen Sie heute nichts mehr und Und ich habe gesagt, klar, ciao, umgekippt. Und naja, es ist die Frage, es gibt ja auch so Adalas und sowas aus dem Mittelalter, kennt man das. Man lässt ab und zu mal Blut ab, damit es einem besser geht. Weg damit! Weirde Idee. Weg mit dem Müllblut. Diese rote Substanz, die alles daran tut, immer im Körper zu bleiben, und selbst wenn es austritt, gerinnt, damit der Rest im Körper bleibt, die nehmen wir raus. Ja, die muss weg. Die muss weg. Nee, und deswegen weiß ich jetzt nicht genau. Mal gucken, vielleicht hat es einen positiven Effekt auf das Podcasting. Ob sich uralte, mittelalterliche Theorien sich bewahrheiten werden in dieser Folge. Ihr werdet es sehen, könnt ihr ja gerne Feedback da lassen. Blöd, dass sie halt Blut auch direkt aus dem Kopfgenommen haben. Ja. Dass sie direkt Nadel, direkt in die Schläfe und da das Blut rausgesaugt haben. Warum da? Warum kriegen nicht alle auch einfach von Anfang an so ein Ding, so ein Hafen gelegt, weißt du? Wie so ein USB-Slot. Ach so, du meinst so wie Neo in der Matrix, der dann so einen Stecker hat. Genau so, sorry, dass ich wieder ausversehen und bewusst sein, stregen Neo. Ähnlich wie unsere Intros pendeln wir zwischen Fluchtecker, Rebik und Matrix hin und her, aber dazwischen kann manchmal hier und da was passieren. Genau, und deswegen finde ich es einfach besser, als immer diese Nadel da reinzurammen, da kann ich auch nicht hingucken. Ja, und dann aber, dann ist irgendwas Witziges passiert, als dir dein Blut abgenommen wurde und dann ist ja immer eine peininliche Situation beim Blutabnehmen und dann, ah, bist du nicht hier, Stefan Tietz, bist du nicht Binky, sag du, oder gab es irgendeine witzige Anekdote, die du erzählen kannst vom Blutabnehmen? Nein. Wenn du in den Stick reingekommen bist und irgendwie, du dachtest, du musst jetzt irgendwie eine Spermaprobe abgeben und hast dir dann mal präventiv was mitgebracht und dann, nein, Herr Tietze, wir meinten eigentlich Blutabnahme.
Ach so, oh.
Was soll ich jetzt damit machen?
Diese ganzen Geschichten.
So was, was witziges halt, was lustiges, was zum Ablachen, Stefan.
Ich war ja da, habe ich ja früher mal erzählt, glaube ich hier auch bereits in diesem Projekt, wegen des Tumors in meinem Kopf.
Das nennt man Gehirn, Stefan, das passt schon. Wegen dieses grossen Äh, dieses Wulstknäuel. Nee, nee, das passt schon so. Ich habe ja diesen so ganz kleinen, mini gutartigen Tumor in meinem Kopf. Einen Freund, kleinen Freund. Einen kleinen Mini-Friend. Und der wurde erkannt, weil ich sehr gross bin, und irgendwann wurde ich hormonell untersucht, ob das denn alles in Maßen sind, weil meine Eltern ganz, ganz winzig klein sind. Und anstatt einen Vaterschaftstest zu machen, der vielleicht hier und da unangenehme Antworten hervorrufen würde, hat man lieber gesagt, nee, lass uns den Freak mal untersuchen. Genau. Anstatt einfach Shaquille O'Neal direkt zu fragen, ob er mein Vater ist, hat man den Freak untersucht, ich, und genau, kam raus, dass Wachstumsvermode leicht erhöht waren und seitdem bin ich, da wurde mein Gehirn emetet und drin gefunden wurde ein kleiner 0,2 cm großer kleiner Tumor, der da hängt, wo er auch vermutet wurde, nämlich an der Hypophyse, wurde aber gesagt, wahrscheinlich hat das keinen Einfluss, er ist auch zu klein, bla bla bla und das ist auch nicht doll erhöht, alles cool, eigentlich alles, ich bin auch nicht unmenschlich gross, also ich bin halt grösser als meine winzig kleinen Mini-Eltern, aber wurde halt dann untersucht und deswegen muss ich regelmäßig zu solchen Tests und das war, beziehungsweise sollte ich das und habe es dann vergessen und das war ich zum ersten Mal seit 15 Jahren war ich wieder bei so einem Test.
Und das, das fremde daran finde ich, dass, weil ich dachte, Gehirne funktionieren komplexer. Ich dachte, Gehirne sind ein riesengroßer komplexer neurologischer Nervenhaufen und da werden so auf so, ja wie so Telepathie werden Informationen von A nach B geschickt und so weiter mit so einem Mini-Elektrowellen, bla bla bla bla. Nein, es ist einfach, du hast eine Hypophyse, werden Hormone ausgedrückt und wenn du einen Tumor hast, dann drückt der da drauf. Und es ist literally ein Button, es ist einfach so ein Knopf, auf den der drückt. Und dann wird das Wachstumshormon ausgedrückt. Es ist nicht so, dass da irgendwie magically Informationen hinkommen und dann wird es ausgestoßen. Nein, das ist so ein roter Buzzer. Das heißt, man könnte theoretisch auch, wenn man da einen langen Finger hat, durchs Ohr, durch die Nase versuchen, durch die Nase versuchen, da drauf zu drücken, um ein bisschen zu wachsen. Genau. Wow. Aber du hast wirklich einen Tumor, der dafür sorgt, dass du so gross bist, wie du bist. Das weiß ich nicht, das weiß man nicht. Das ist ja genau das, was herausgefunden werden sollte. Oder es ist andersrum, gerade weil du so viel Wachstumshormone hast, hat der Tumor gesagt, da wohne ich. Location, Location, Location. Weil der Knopf gedrückt werden muss, hat der Kopf sich entschieden, dass er da einfach wie so eine Beschwerung, so ein Gewicht drauflegt. Ja, so dieser Vogel, der immer auf die Taste drückt, wenn man selber zu faul ist. Wenn mein Gehirn zu faul war, selber immer drauf zu drücken. Aber ich finde das faszinierend, dass das Gehirn dann doch am Ende dieser komplexe Haufen dann doch so haptisch ist. Ja, aber auch gruselig, weil so einfach sollte es doch nicht sein. Aber hast du mal irgendwie dein Zwilling absorbiert oder so, dass das so ein zweites Gehirn in deinem Gehirn ist? Das ist der 0,2 Zentimeter große. Irgendwie sowas? Ich weiß es nicht, es bleibt spannend. Also ich finde das auch, das ist eine coole Abteilung, die Endokrinologie. Ich sag's auch gern. Man muss schon mal sagen, du bist schon so eine Art, ja. Wissenschaftliches Wunder. Ja, du bist schon was, also eine Art Supermensch. Weil du erstens bist immun gegen Aids, zweitens hast du ein zweites Minigehirn in deinem Gehirn. Also ich will jetzt nicht sagen, pflanz dich fort, aber ich glaube, du pflanz dich auf jeden Fall fort und pflanz dich auf gar keinen Fall fort. Nein, ich glaube, wir gehen mit dir in eine gute Richtung. Ich glaube, die Menschheit geht mit dir in eine richtig gute Richtung. Erstmal immun gegen AIDS, erstmal super. Zweitens, wer weiß, in 100 Generationen ist dieser gutartige Tumor vielleicht so eine Art zweiten Gehirn herangewachsen, so eine Art zweites Bewusstsein oder so eine Art externe Festplatte, wo man auch noch mehr Erinnerungen drauf speichern kann oder irgendwie sowas in der Richtung. Vielleicht bist du echt der Fortschritt. Schade, dass du dich so wenig fortpflanzt. Schade, dass es nicht passiert. Ich habe aber jetzt die Hoffnung ein bisschen, dass das entfernt werden muss vielleicht und ihr hier im Podcast für die Wissenschaft eine Charakteränderung feststellen könnt. Oh, das finde ich nicht schlecht, weil tatsächlich ist ja dein Charakter sehr gut dokumentiert mit 297 Podcastfolgen.olgen. Genau, und irgendwann sagt man dann so, vor Gehirn-OP, nach Gehirn-OP, werden dann so die Podcast-Folgen unterteilt und nach, er wurde extrem schlechter, der Podcast, nach der Gehirn-OP fände ich eigentlich auch mal einfach spannend, dass dokumentiert ist. Weil es ist schon schwer, wenn man dann sagt, hat sich ihr Charakter geändert seit der Operation und du sagst, keine Ahnung, kann man ja selber nicht werden. Aber ist ja der neue Charakter, der spricht, der anfängt los zu plappern. Ja, der sagt ja nicht, nee, ich bin jetzt viel lamer als davor. Der hat ja auch ein Ego. Von daher ist es gar nicht so schlecht, dass wir glücklicherweise dieses Projekt begonnen haben, um einfach dich zu dokumentieren. Genau, ist ja die ganz alte spannende Frage. Sophie Passmann hat da auch neulich sehr spannend darüber erzählt
in der Instagram-Story, dass sie lange Angst hatte, in Therapie zu gehen.
Weil sie dachte, dass die Sachen, die ihr Probleme bereiten,
die auch für Depressionen oder depressive Phasen und so sorgen,
ja, vielleicht auch die Teile in ihrem Charakter sind,
die sie lustig werden lassen.
Weil Humor natürlich auch eine Form von Distanz und Bewältigung und so was ist. Und deswegen glaube ich auch Leute, die sowas machen, was wir machen, dazu neigen, lieber nichts zu verändern, weil es ist ja bislang ganz gut gegangen. Das muss man sich aber auch von lösen, einfach, das ist ja völliger Unsinn. Also nichts, was einen schlecht drauf macht, sorgt ja dafür, dass man besser und lustiger ist. Nehmen wir nochmal weitere 300 Folgen und dann mach wieder eine starke Charakteränderung, alle 300 Folgen. Machst du eine starke Charakteränderung? Lobotomie, nach allen 300 Folgen. Ja, einfach mal rein. Einfach mal ein Jahr nur als Handstand leben. Einfach mal alles umdrehen oder so. Ich bin super gespannt. Also wahrscheinlich ist alles gut. Das ist lame ein bisschen. Heute musste ich dann dafür, da wird getestet, ob dieser, genau, ob das da drauf drückt, auf diesen Button, wurde getestet, indem ich 100 Gramm Fruchtzucker trinken musste.
und dann wurde jede halbe Stunde mir sehr viel Blut abgenommen, um zu gucken, weil das müsste normalerweise das Wachstumshormon senken, weil der Körper sagt, wer das auch immer rausgefunden hat,
dachte ich mir dann, als ich da drei Stunden lang in dem Labor saß, mitten im Labor, während um mich herum
wo Drüchkemgewuselt wurde, habe ich da gesessen mit meinen Gedanken allein und überlegt, wer ist darauf gekommen, dass wenn Glucose dem Körper zugefügt wird, dass das Gehirn sagt, nur jetzt kein Wachstumshormon mehr. Heißt das im Umkehrschluss, wenn man Zucker isst, wächst man nicht mehr? Weiß ich nicht. Oder wenn man wenig Zucker isst, wächst man ganz gross? Moment, du hast nicht mal eine Brigitte bekommen oder sowas? Nichts. Ich sass da. Die setzt nicht da einfach drei Stunden hin und du kriegst nicht mal ein lustiges Taschenbuch oder sowas? Gar nichts. Ich habe mir Bücher mitgebracht, aber die lagen dann ganz woanders. Und dann wollte ich auch nicht fragen, hatten ja auch viel zu tun. Du sass drei Stunden einfach da. Ja, einfach im Raum. Ja. Wie geht das? Ich habe mein Handy noch gehabt. Ah, okay. Aber pass auf, ich habe am Anfang gesagt, weil ich weiß, dass die Venen am rechten, meine rechten Hand besser sind, um Blut abzunehmen, weil die loben mich immer beim rechten Arm. Und Tadel, nicht beim linken. Tadel, nicht beim linken. Beim linken ist es immer so, es ist schwierig, bei ihnen die Venen zu finden, und ich sage immer, ja, scheiße. Und deswegen schwöre ich mir immer, sag rechts, weil es ist zwar dein Arm, den du brauchst, aber es ist der Arm, wo du für deine Venen gelogen bist.
Okay, das ist eine schwere Abwägung, aber interessant, dass du dich so entschieden hast. Dann habe ich heute gesagt, rechts. Und grosses Lob bekommen für meine Venen, wieder, again, zieht sich durch. Dass du auch immer noch gerne annimmst. Das nehme ich gerne an und immer so, das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Und führt aber dazu, dass ich dann da saß, ohne Brigitte, mitten im Raum und das Handy mit links bedienen musste, was nicht geht. Und du warst angeschlossen mit rechts, da waren dann Kabel im Arm und du kundest nicht. Da war ein Kabel im Arm und so Kochsalz, shit und das war einfach fucking weird. Und ich hasse das. Jetzt habe ich kein Blut mehr im Körper und ich weiß nicht, was das bedeutet. Wie viel Blut hat man im Körper? Sag mal eine Zahl. Habst du neun Liter oder sowas? Neun Liter oder sowas in der Ecke. Aber das ist ja auch nicht alles am selben Ort, das ist ja überall. Ist es denn überall? Also ist jede Ader in meinem Körper voll mit Blut? Ja, ich glaube schon. Das kann ja nirgendwo nicht sein. Ich glaube, sonst hättest du nicht diese Gesichtsfarbe. Ich glaube ja so, bei Leichen, die werden ja bleich, weil das Blut weg... Sofort verdunstet. Das ist sofort weg. Naja, man sagt immer, man wird leichter beim Eintritt des Todes. Vielleicht, weil das Blut verschwindet wie ein Jedi. Achtsig Gramm oder so was? Weil die Mediklorianer ... Nee, aber zum Beispiel, wenn du irgendwie Fieber hast, dann wirst du rot im Gesicht, weil du mehr durchblutet wirst. Ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Nur in der Badewanne, ich merke es ja an meinem eigenen Körper, wenn ich zum Hummer werde, wenn ich ins Wasser gehe, ich bade ja sehr heiß und dann merke ich, dass ich sehr rot werde und denke, jetzt habe ich mehr Blut plötzlich. Nein, es ist nur weiter außen, weil das Blut versucht, seinem Körper zu entfliehen, diesem kochend heißen, weirden Moment zu entfliehen. Weil ich verstehe, dass das Blut dahin geht, wo es jetzt gerade gebraucht wird. Ich verstehe nicht, woher es kommt. Wo ist denn wo ist denn dann irgendwo kein Blut mehr? Ich dachte, Adern, alle Adern sind voll, randvoll, das ist mein, weil es darf ja auch kein Sauerstoff, wenn die Adern kommen. Ne, deswegen bei Pulp Fiction und so hast du dann immer den Shot auf die Spritze und dann wird der oben rausgespritzt und dann wird so gegengetropft, damit oben der Sauerstoff rauskommt. Cool, cool, cool. Einfach sieht stark aus, dieser Microshot. Ja, aber jetzt lass uns über den Penis reden. Der als Schwellkörper manchmal Blut drin hat und manchmal nicht. Das heißt, du musst ja Blutreserven haben. Aber wo kommen die denn her, frage ich dich? Naja, halt über Blutdruck halt. Da sagst du, hast du halt weniger Druck in den anderen Bereichen. Ach, ich weiß es auch nicht genau. Aber ich dachte mir heute anzieht. Du hattest drei Stunden Zeit, diese Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler alles zu fragen. Nein, die waren alle beschäftigt. Ja, als ob die sagen würden, nee, das sage ich dir jetzt nicht. Wenn du sagst, Entschuldigung, Frau Doktor, wie funktioniert das denn, wo kommt das Blut her? Ja, aber die hat so einen Arm in der Hand. Nee, das sage ich dir jetzt nicht. Nee, das darf ich jetzt trotzdem antworten. Die sagt, können Sie bitte Ihre Klappe halten? Ich hab hier gerade einen abgetrennten Arm von diesem Patienten da drüben in der Hand. Da war viel los, ich war wie so ein Bienenstock und da war so ein Rumgewusel. Ich war da nicht, ich hab mich da nicht so zu Hause gefühlt. Hattest du Angst, dass man dich vergisst? Nee, weil die ganze Zeit, während ich da saß, eine sehr laute Eieruhr neben mir stand, die aber alle halbe Stunde musste mit Blut entnommen werden, um zu gucken, ob da dieses Hormonschissel losgeht oder aufhört. Und dann hatte ich eine Eieruhr und die ganze Zeit hat die so geklangen. Oh Gott. Und dann war es abgelaufen, die halbe Stunde, und dann war es ... Deswegen, ich hatte zu keinem Zeitpunkt Angst, dass ich vergessen werde. Ich habe nur das Gefühl gehabt, die hätten auch genug zu tun, wenn ich nicht da gewesen wäre. Und du hast überlegt, ich könnte den anbieten. ,,Drrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr Aber er tickt so wenigstig die ganze Zeit, ja. Du bist Windhorn? Nebelhorn. Nebelhorn, fuck, so nah. Nebelhorn, so nah. Okay. Ja, jetzt kommen die ganzen Gags, die du in deiner Segelprüfung endlich dir mal angeschafft hast, kannst du endlich mal ausnutzen. Nebelhorn, verdammt, so nah. Okay. Du weißt, das war auf der Art dein Unterbewusstsein, was diesen fantastischen Gag gemacht hat.
Aber du bist Typ Nebelhorn?
Ich bin Typ Nebelhorn, ja. Also du hast dich nicht für das klassische Xylophon entschieden, sondern gesagt, nee, ich brauche was eigenes, ich bin Stefan Tietze, ich habe nicht wieder das Xylophon, sondern ich nehme das Nebelhorn? Ja, Nebelhorn schiesst mich aus dem Bett. Nee, aber ohne Scheiss, ich frag mich jetzt, als mir diese ganzen Lieder abgenommen wurden, dachte ich mir, sind meine Adern jetzt vielleicht, das ist das Ergebnis, zu dem ich gekommen bin, meine Adern passen sich der Blutmenge meines Körpers an und ziehen sich eher zusammen, dachte ich jetzt. Jetzt habe ich so ganz dünne Äderchen in meinem Körper, dachte ich jetzt. Ja. Weil ich dachte, da gab kein Sauerstoff rein und deswegen sind die halt immer voll, weil Vakuum macht ja auch keinen Sinn, ne, würdest du mir da zustimmen?
Ja.
Und deswegen glaube ich, dass man das Adern-
Ja, oder halt weniger Druck, dass wenn du jetzt normalerweise stichst du in die Ader und das spritzt raus und dann stichst du in die Ader und es tröpfelt nur so raus.
Also es ist mehr sozusagen, aber das wird ja auch nicht, die Dichte steigt ja auch nicht, oder?
Also es kann schon sein, dass die sich wie so Gummischläuche ausdehnen, die Adern und so.
Du, wie gesagt, du saßt drei Stunden bei Experten und hast keine dieser Fragen gestellt, also da darfst du mich jetzt auch nicht so dumm angucken gerade. Die wissen das ja auch nicht. Die wissen wie man Blut abnimmt.
Das ist die ersten 20 Minuten Medizinstudium.
Ich glaube, wir müssten wirklich 40 Minuten Medizinstudium und hätten alle Fragen beantwortet, die wir jemals in diesem Podcast gestellt haben. Weil das absoluten Basics sind. Das Erste, was du ja machst, ist dann irgendwie der Handstand mit, oh, man kann Dinge runterschlucken, auch wegen dem Handstand und alle so what? Und dann dann hast du schon, weil das sind die ersten Minuten Medizinstudium, dann wie funktioniert Blutdruck und dann einfach nochmal 35 Minuten Schwellkörper. Daran erkennst du auch, wenn du jetzt quasi zu mir kommst und ich bin so Sekretariat an der Uni und du sagst, du bist Medizinstudent und ich sage, folgen sie einfach den what-Schreien, dann finden sie die im Saal, dann finden sie ihren richtigen Hörsaal, weil das erste Semester ist immer nur in so einem Zehn-Minuten-Takt so ein What? Also es gibt ja diesen Bereich im Gehirn und wenn da was draufdrückt, dann wächst der Mensch. Was? Ganze Saal. Nochmal, was? Wie so eine Laola-Welle, so von vorne nach hinten. Was? Ja, das ist schwierig. Aber das ist schon toll. Also du bist so groß, weil du diesen kleinen Freund im Kopf hast. Das heißt, jede Charaktereigenschaft wird von irgendeinem Knubbel begründet, der da irgendwo drauf drückt? Wahnsinn. Kern ist man entweder eine Computertastatur und überall drücken Dinge drauf und am Ende steht da ein Charakter.
Aber die haben jetzt das Wachstumshormon in deinem Blut gemessen, aber du wächst ja jetzt nicht mehr, oder?
Das gilt es herauszufinden, weil die Krankheit, die es auszuschliessend gilt, heisst Agromegalie. Und das ist Riesenwuchs, Riesenwuchs. Aber darunter leide ich nicht, dafür bin ich auch viel zu klein. Ach so, der hört nie auf, das Wachstumshormon rauszudrücken, deswegen wächst man sein Leben dann weiter. Aber die haben richtige Oschis in ihrem Kopf an Tumoren, die dann voll Pullblown auf diesen Button drücken. Und dann wächst du immer weiter, dein Leben lang wächst du weiter. Auch die Knochen und alles wächst weiter. Genau, und das Problem ist halt, dass du irgendwann keine Wachstumsspalten mehr hast, heisst, deine Knöchel werden immer so gross, weil Dinge gegeneinander stoßen, und du kriegst so dicke Augenbrauen vor, Wülste und kriegst so sehr grobe Gesichtszüge. Wow. Und das ist halt dann nicht so geil. Und da hab ich dann keine Lust drauf und hätte ich verhindern müssen. Aber das hab ich nicht. Also so schlimm ist es auch nicht. Es ist auch nicht so viel. Es ist nur, ich hab es gerade so, dass diese Tests durchgeführt werden und ich viel lerne. Ich nehm es als Lernerfahrung mit. Ja, find ich gut. Find ich schlecht. Ich find's schon spannend. Ich finde es richtig spannend. Ich bin sehr gespannt, zu sehen, was mit dir weiter passiert, wie du dich veränderst und wie du dich schon verändert hast. Hörst du mal in alte Folgen rein und denkst dir, wow, da habe ich mich echt verändert. So spritzig, knackig bin ich nicht mehr wie damals. Da war ich viel schneller im Kopf. Was ist da denn los? Ja. Fuck, Tumor war kleiner. Ich weiß es nicht. Ich glaube, dass man schon eine Charakterveränderung feststellen kann. Findest du das nicht? Das ist ja schon krass, wie heftig wir dokumentiert sind. Also generell unsere Generation ja schon, durch die vielen Fotos, aber jetzt auch wir beiden im Speziellen, durch als Podcast. Hast du mal in Folge drei oder so reingehört Nee, nee, ich mach das nicht mehr. Mach das nicht mehr?
Aber das war das Aufgehört,
diesen Prozess. Ich glaube, am Anfang
habe ich schon die Folge nochmal gehört, aber dann
nicht mehr, weil du bist mir auch auf die Nerven gegangen.
Ich habe noch eine Frage, ich habe noch eine letzte Frage
zum Thema Blut. Du meintest, du musstest
Zuckerwasser
oder Glucosewasser
trinken. Jetzt kommt Frage A,
wie gut war das geschmeckt? Ja. Frage B, wie viel? Also wie hast du das bekommen? War das so ein Shotglas oder mit einem Strohhalm? Das war der erste große Lacher für mich an dem Morgen. Es ist immer gut, wenn der erste Lacher früh kommt. Weil ich dachte, ich krieg das als, als, entweder als schönes Becherchen oder als Flasche direkt sogar, wo ich oben was aufmachen kann.
Und es war einfach so ein, naja, ich würde sagen, so ein Becher, wo was am Bett hängt, wo Leute reinpinkeln.
Es war so ein Messbecher, so ein grosser, so ein Labording.
Nichts daran hat gesagt, hier raus trinkst du jetzt bitte.
Alles daran hat gesagt, das hier ist für Abfälle, für Säure, für schlimme, schlimme Medizin, Finger weg. Und daraus musste ich dann, das hatte so ein, wie so ein Messbecher, den man im Prinzip aus Laboren kennt. Das hatte so einen großen Henkel und das war einfach nur, hat geschmeckt wie Dextro Energy Kirsch. Das war sehr lecker, ehrlich gesagt. Und dann musste ich ganz schnell trinken. Echsen.
Ganz schnell? Man würde fast sagen, Echsen. Auf einen Schluck, 200 Milliliter.
100 Milliliter. 100 Gramm Zucker. Ich weiß nicht, wie viele Liter das waren. Ich glaube, es waren so 500 Milliliter.
100 Gramm, das ist aber ganz schön viel. Genau, genau, genau.
Du darfst jetzt aber heute nicht mehr viel naschen, Stefan. Nee, heute darf ich nicht mehr so viel naschen.
Nee, dafür heute ist aber jetzt auch genug, ne? Nee, musst du wirklich gucken. Nicht, dass du wieder nicht schlafen kannst, Stefan. Ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne,, dass du wieder nicht schlafen kannst, Stefan. Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Ein Snickers. Nee, nee, 100 Gramm Zucker ist schon mehr als die tägliche Dosis, mein Lieber. Ist ja viel, ist richtig viel. Richtig viel, ja. Na gut, und das muss jetzt heraus, also irgendwie aus irgendwelchen Gründen, führt das dann dazu, dass das Wachstum von Hormonen nicht mehr ausgeschüttet wird. Ich bin sehr gespannt. Ich krieg vielleicht sogar während der Folge das Ergebnis. Das wäre natürlich fantastisch. Der Arzt kann kurz einhand gesagt, ich rufe dich heute an. Haben wir eine Schattenwand hier, dass der Arzt hinter eine Schattenwand kann oder so? Soll ich den on air fragen, was passiert, wenn man zu wenig Brüder im Körper hat? Ja, frag den. Der weiß es bestimmt, der sagt, ja keine Ahnung, sorry, ich stehe jetzt komplett auf dem Schlauch. Sorry, aber jetzt stehe hier komplett auf dem Schlauch. Ich muss hier kurz weggehen.
Ja, wirklich, ich stehe hier gerade. Ich bin komplett blank.
Ich stehe hier auf dem Schlauch. Ich stehe hier auf einem grossen Schlauch. Ich sollte hier nicht stehen. Ich sollte aber auch nicht aus dem Labor Leute anrufen.
Das ist, glaube ich, eine der wenigen Feuerwehr-Metaphern, oder? Dass kein Wasser kommt, weil irgendjemand ein Trottel auf dem Schlauch steht. Und es kommt kein Wasser, oder? Also ansonsten, glaube ich, allerhöchst, nee. Ich glaube, ansonsten gibt es wenig Metaphern aus der Welt der Feuerwehr. Aber eigentlich auch falsch übernommen, weil mittlerweile sagt man eher, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch. Das sind aber nie die Leute, die gesagt haben, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch. Ja, obwohl wenn du dann halt so, du willst jetzt dein Wasser spritzen und du denkst, warum kommt denn da nichts? Ach, hä, ich habe doch den Hydranten angeschlossen. Ach Gott, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch. Nee, aber das würde man nicht sagen. Man würde erst mal runtergehen und dann sagen, ich stand auf dem Schlauch. Oder was man jetzt gerade ja sagt, ist, ich glaube, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch. Das stimmt. Das ist ein Satz, der jemand, wenn er draufsteht, würde nie sagen würde.
Ja, das stimmt. Eigentlich, wenn du sagst, ich stehe auf dem Schlauch, hast du ja noch gerade nicht die Lösung des Problems.
Ja.
Wogegen für den Feuerwehrmann ist das ja schon die Lösung.
Er würde es nicht sagen, weil er würde das Erste, was er tun würde, ist sagen, ach, und dann würde er vom Schlauch stehen.
Ja, wahrscheinlich mit so einem, ich mal wieder.
Und dann die Leute retten aus dem brennenden Haus.
Ich stehe auf dem Schlauch, stimmt, Feuerwehr mit Haftwaren geht es sonst nicht, ne?
Da kommen die, schneller als die Feuerwehr?
Ja, als die Feuerwehr erlaubt ist.
Ne.
Leiter hoch.
Kein Thing.
Bitte machen Sie die Einfahrt frei. Nein, ist kein Sprichwort. Bitte achten Sie auf den Brandschutz. Okay, auch kein Sprichwort, aber verstehe ich schon. Wo Rauch ist, ist auch Feuer. Okay, das gefällt mir. Jetzt haben wir es natürlich. Wo Hobel sind, fallen Späne. Ja, ich weiß, aber es ist schwierig. Vielleicht können ein paar Feuerwehrleute uns da auch ein bisschen auf die Sprünge helfen. Schaust du Olympia gerade? Ne, überhaupt nicht. Ganz, ganz wenig. Es ist immer so, ich habe eine Person, der ich folge auf Twitter, die ist wahnsinnig Olympia begeistert. Und da sehe ich immer jetzt Medaille hier, Medaille da, Pferd umgefallen,
Skifahrer hat seine
Schlepppferd, hat seinen Ski verloren,
der ist vom Lift runtergefallen
und so und dann denke ich mir, okay,
das reicht mir schon. Pferde gibt es ja nicht,
Pferde gibt es ja nicht im Wintersport,
es gibt nur Eisbärenrennen,
wo mal Leute wilde Eisbären
dressiert haben und auf denen
über Hindernisse gehen.
Pferde sind auch sehr filigran,
die können dann ab und zu auch so schön laufen
Vielen Dank. wo mal Leute wilde Eisbären dressiert haben und auf denen über Hindernisse gehen. Pferde sind auch sehr filigran, die können dann ab und zu auch so schön laufen und so. Das wäre auch mal geil auf Eisbären, einfach, dass Eisbären dann so schön tippeln und nur auf den Vordertatzen gehen. Ich glaube, Pferde werden nicht so schlecht auf dem Eis. Also ich glaube, die kriegen das hin mit den Hufeisen, wo der Mensch eh schon sagt, Hufe. das können wir besser. Das können wir besser. Gib mal kurz her, gib mal deinen Huf. Wir ballern da was drunter. Gib mal deinen Huf her, ich mach mal was, ich mach mal was. Und dann schau mal wie. Über einen Schnitt und dann so ein kleines Schuhchen. Und es fährt einfach Wow, Wow, bin ich schnell, Wow, Wow, einfach wahnsinnig schnell. wie jeder zweite Akt in so einem Film, so How to Turn, Train Your Dragon mässig. Woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, woa, und dann huuuuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuhuuh Fantastisch. Ne, ich gucke sehr gern. Ich liebe das gerade. Ich gucke, das ist wahnsinnig beruhigend. Auch so vormittags Fernsehen anzumachen, finde ich ganz toll gerade. Das finde ich super. Und dann läuft da Biathlon, dann läuft da Skispring. Und die Deutschen kriegen gerade sehr viele Medaillen, aber nur, weil sie halt irgendwie diesen Rodelsport aus irgendwelchen Gründen dominieren. Irgendwie spannend, weil es ist auch das Lame-Zie. Ach, die Achishorsch. Den habe ich gesehen am Königssee damals. Medaillengewinner. War der erste Promi, den ich hier gesehen habe. Und mittlerweile hast du ja viele Leute gesehen. Weniger als man denkt. Nee, also nicht als ich denke. Ich glaube, ich habe gesehen Lars Eidinger und Ronja von Rönne. Und das war's. Und Hackelschorsch. Und Hackelschorsch. Gute Gruppe, ehrlich gesagt. Das sind so meine Top drei auch. Eigentlich die, die auf meiner Liste stehen. Mehr wollte ich gar nicht sehen. Mehr Olympia-Gewinner wollte ich gar nicht sehen eigentlich. Das reicht mir jetzt schon. Wo du das gerade sagst, so eine illustre Gruppe, die ich mir so vorstellen hätte können bei der Stock Car Crash Challenge als Team. Mhm. Da habe ich gedacht, wie sehr ich das vermisse. Die Stock Car Crash Challenge. Die Stefan-Raab-Events. Weil ich dachte, ich habe manchmal gehofft, so, weil das lief ja noch, als wir auch dann angefangen haben mit dem Podcast und so, und irgendwann dachte ich, da habe ich mich so darauf gefreut, vielleicht mal eines Tages, irgendwann mal, vielleicht bekannt genug dafür zu sein, das war der einzige Grund, warum ich bekannt sein wollte, bei der Stalker-Crash-Challenge mitzumachen. Weil ich fand das so fucking awesome.
So cool. Und jetzt gibt es das einfach nicht mehr. Ja, das macht niemand so, diese ganzen Twitch-Streamer oder so, die sind alle vernetzt, aber die machen halt nicht so diese Live-Sachen dann vielleicht, diese grossen Sachen. Aber da gibt es bestimmt wieder irgendjemanden, der sowas macht. Die Stalker-Crash-Challenge, war sowas Cooles in der Welt. Autoball, Autoball war auch Rock-WM, ja. Autoball war richtig cool, hab ich mal live gesehen. Das waren auch komische Events, weil das irgendwie gar nicht so, wo man auch das Gefühl hatte, die Promis strengen sich gar nicht an, jetzt irgendwie lustig oder schlagfertig zu sein, sondern die sind da halt einfach, so wie sie privat mit ihren Kumpels Go-Kart fahren würden. Und selbst so ein Olli Pocher, der hat halt mal hier und da einen Gag gemacht, aber es war jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt, die sind da, um zu performen, sondern die sind einfach da, um da mitzumachen. Das war sehr deutsch, die wollten dann auch gewinnen. Ja, absolut. Die waren dann auch sehr, vor allem ehrgeizig, die waren nicht als Unterhalter da oder so, um den Leuten draußen einen guten Abend zu machen, sondern um selber eine gute Zeit zu haben. Es war irgendwie so, Leute kommen zusammen, wollen dann aber auch gewinnen. Ja. Und haben auch noch Anschlusstermine, so wirkst du immer. Müsst dann auch noch weg, ja, stimmt schon. Ja, ich habe bei mir gerade, ich bin tatsächlich ein bisschen angespannt, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, weil ich muss ehrlich zugeben, er ist ein Hausstaub, ich schaue schon immer auf die Uhr, wie lange das einfach noch dauert, weil ich habe noch glaube ich so gute 20 Minuten oder so und dann wird hier losgetriegt. 20 Minuten Höfel! Und der Grund dafür, ich lebe ja wirklich im Dreck. Also ich lebe ja wirklich im Dreck gerade.
Ich habe keinen Grund aufzuräumen, null, nichts. Der Grund dafür, ich lebe ja wirklich im Dreck. Also ich lebe ja wirklich im Dreck gerade.
Ich habe keinen Grund aufzuräumen, null, nichts.
Und das ist, glaube ich, für jeden Messi wie mich das schlimmste Nachricht, die man bekommen kann, wenn du nach Hause kommst und an der Tür hast du den Zettel Heizungsinspektionen und denkst dir, fuck, und plötzlich alle diese Aufgaben, die du vor dich, diese Haushaltsaufgaben, die du vor dir hergeschoben hast, kommen als Lawine auf dich zurück und du scheiße die Heizung, scheiße die Kartons, oh Staubsaugen, oh verdammt, da rüttelt irgendwas, oh nein, das ist laut, oh nein, das habe ich immer noch nicht weggeräumt. Alles kommt plötzlich und das musst du alles machen. Aber das erste Problem, was mir noch in Erinnerung geblieben ist, war das verschopfte Rohr.
Ja, das konnte aber gelöst werden mit massiver chemischer Gewalt. Da habe ich ja schön einfach da einen Liter von diesem... Genau, das ist aber das komplett geklärt. Das ist auch für den Preis von 200 Südseefischen konnte mein Abfluss tatsächlich gelöst werden und das klappt. Da bin ich sehr, sehr froh. Weil dein Rohr direkt in die Südsee geht, das wissen auch viele nicht. Ja, tatsächlich. Wo du das Rohr geht direkt, wirklich ohne Umzweige in die Südsee. Einfach direkt, deswegen war es auch verstopft, weil die Fische teilweise auch vom Meer reinschwimmen und stecken bleiben, weil Fische haben keinen Rückwärtsgang. Fische sind Idioten. Ja, komplette Vollidioten und genauso wie Kängurus können sich nicht rückwärts bewegen. Also wenn die sich mal vermanövrieren, war es das. Wenn ein Känguru sich in der Ecke manövriert, dann ist es erledigt, weil es kommt nicht mehr weg. Es kommt auch nicht häufig vor, dass Sackgassen in der Natur sind, eher auch kein Konzept. Ja, aber manchmal schon. Manchmal, wenn du da, was ist denn da? Ein Stein? Aha, Berg? Ein Baum? Was ist denn? Ist da was Kleines? Kann ich was? Oh nein! Oh nein! Man kommt einfach nicht weg, man hat einfach keinen Rückwärtsgang mehr und man ist geliefert. Ich verstehe das nicht. Das ist ja auch das Konzept von Aalreusen. Ne? Ne?
Weil du weisst, wie Aalreusen rausreisen. Weisst du, wie die aussehen? Die können sich nicht mehr rausreisen.
Ne, du hast ja, das ist ja wie ein Trichter, ne? Und die können reinschwimmen, aber die können nicht wieder rauskommen. Jetzt ist meine Frage, warum nicht? Du hattest drei Stunden Zeit, jede Frage zu stellen, und du hast nichts gemacht. Du hast in deiner linken tollpatschigen Hand aufs Handy gestarrt und hast aus Versehen lauter Bilder geliked von irgendwelchen alten Klassenkameraden. Deswegen können Sie mir sagen, warum alle nicht aus Aalreusen herauskommen? Und dann zieht die so einen Vorhang zu, die im Krankenhaus immer so rippt und schsch, die gab's wirklich, die gab's wirklich. Wenn ich eine so eine Vorhang gestellt habe, wäre mein Vorhang gekommen. Der Faust knallt. Du hast eine Chance. Du kommst da ins Krankenhaus und der Vorhang ist offen. Er war offen. Eine Chance. Er war offen. Wenn du eine dumme Frage stellst und du bist einfach alleine. Diese Vorhänge gibt es an zwei Orten. Im Krankenhaus und in der ersten Klasse bei Flugzeugen. Oh ja. Wenn ich dann immer in der zweiten Klasse sitze und dann kommt vorne immer diese Frau ... Gibt's was Tolleres als Diskretion? Ist das Geräusch? Dass du einfach sagst ... Das ist das Geräusch von Ich bin was besseres als du. We are better than you. Perfekt. Das ist grossartig. Es ist auch beim Krankenhaus ein Ich bin was besseres als du. Du Idiot, geh mir nicht auf die Nerven. Da frag mich doch einmal, warum Aale nicht aus Aalehäusern herauskommen.
Aber das bräuchte man auch grossflächig in Zügen,
dass einfach, wenn dich irgendjemand nervt,
du einfach so einen kleinen Vorhang vorschieben kannst.
Aber warum nicht diese, warum nicht Kappen machen,
die so eine Stange um sich herum, so einen Duschvorhangstange um sich herum haben,
so eine Imkerartige Konstruktion.
Du hast so einen kleinen Vorhang vor dir. Ja, einen Kreis rund. Ja, im Kreis rund um dich herum, wie so ein großer Sombrero. Wie lang ist der aber dann, bis zum Boden oder nur so auf Hüfthöhe, im Barlokal? Nee, nee, auf Kniehöhe, äh, Kinnhöhe. Kinnhöhe. Auf Kinnhöhe. Das ist so nur einfach, das ist ja nur Sichtschutz auch, im Krankenhaus ist es Sichtschutz, in der Firstklasse ist es Sichtschutz, damit wir nicht sehen, was die dann in der zweiten Klasse, in der ersten Klasse machen. Das weisst du ja gar nicht, was da passiert. Weiss niemand. Das können wir uns ja gar nicht vorstellen. Man hört manchmal Geräusche so, war das ein Krokodil? Du hast so Ahnungen, aber du hast... Ja, weil die einfach alle Jumanji 2 gucken. Die beste Zeit davon. Und wir müssen immer nur dieselben Filme gucken. Wir dürfen nicht Jumanji sehen, wir müssen immer Rosamunde Peche schauen. Wir müssen Rilke lesen. Rilke lesen. Die dürfen Jumanji schauen und Crocodile Dundee und wir nicht. Typisches Erst-, Zweite-Klasse-Problem kennt jeder. Rilke lesen und Tauben im Gras. Und drüben die dürfen Shrek gucken. Bei denen ist immer sechste Stunde. Bei uns ist immer Montag erste. Aber ich habe es mir jetzt echt überlegt zum Thema Zug. Ich habe recherchiert, ich habe recherchiert, pass auf. Und zwar. Du musst nämlich gleich die Aufräumklammer zumachen. Absolut gerne. Mein Problem ist, ich fahre ja viel Zug, ich pendel Hamburg, Köln und ich habe immer das Problem, ich sitze im Ruheabteil, die Leute sind nicht ruhig. Oft spreche ich sie darauf an, sie sitzen im Ruheabteil und sind nicht ruhig. Sehen sie das Problem? Sagt das genauso? Ja. Auch mit dieser passiv agressiven, sehen sie das Problemfrage? Och Gott, ey. Ich bin auf deren Seite jetzt. Und das Problem, das ich sehe, ist, dass die meisten Leute gar nicht wissen, dass sie im Ruheabteil sind. Wüssten sie es, weil die sind ja oft auch gar nicht so voll. Das heißt, wüssten sie es und würden sie wahrscheinlich auch sich anders verhalten.
Das heißt, ich habe mir jetzt wirklich überlegt, auf eigene Faust druck ich mir hunderte Sticker aus, die aber auch so aussehen wie von der Bahn designt. Also wirklich so, und diese Sticker klebt sie an die Rückseite der Lehne, also so dass die Leute es direkt vor sich haben. Und es ist wirklich so gross wie die ganze obere Teil der Lehne. Und ich designe das wirklich professionell, halt wie in dem Bahndesign mit der richtigen Font, mit den Farben. Genau, DB-Font, kannst du bestimmt drunterlad runterladen. Farben und dann irgendwie so eine entspannte Frau, die dann da sitzt und irgendwie dann entspannt. Und dann so, ah, sie sind im Ruheabteil mit irgend so einem flotten Spruch. Und das lasse ich mir professionell drucken und klebe das auf eigene Faust. Immer hinter deinen Sitz? Hinter, nee, hinter alle. In dem ganzen Waggon. Moment, das heißt du gehst dann. Nee, nee, das muss ja schon hinter allen sein.. Und ich frag mich, und ich hab wirklich da jetzt viel Zeit und auch ein bisschen Geld investiert mittlerweile,
dass ich mir überlege, würde das jemand wieder abnehmen?
Weil das wird ja auffallen, den Offiziellen von der Bahn.
Würden die das abnehmen oder sagen die, ja warum nicht? Weil das ist jetzt nicht, dass das irgendwie als Gäckig ist oder da irgendwas Obszönes draufsteht,
sondern schlicht und einfach, Sie sind hier im Ruheabteil, genießen Sie die Ruhe oder was auch immer. Also ich verschreibe es dabei noch wahrscheinlich. Und dann, denke ich mir nicht, würde da wirklich dann da irgend so ein Bahnmitarbeiter durchgehen und die alle abknibbeln? Meine Frage ist jetzt erstmal, wie willst du es anstellen und reicht nicht wirklich der fünf Meter Radius um deinen Sitz herum? Also quasi, dass du sagst, du bist der Erste... Aber das ist ja sofort als Vandalismus erkennbar.
Das muss ja wirklich durch den ganzen Waggon sein, dass es überall ist, dass jetzt vielleicht die neuen Stich. Wie willst du das anstellen? Du musst dir ja auch noch ein Bahnoutfit kaufen. Nein, ich kleb das da hin. Du kannst doch nicht, wenn du, der Zug fährt in Köln ein, da sitzen jetzt schon, der kommt dann nach Süsseldorf und so, fährt weiter nach München, keine Ahnung. Da sitzen ja jetzt schon 15 Leute in dem Abteil. Und du willst quasi mit deinen, mit deinen Jogginghosen, mit deinem normalen, ich fahr hier auch nur mit Outfit, über die drüberlangen und denen vor ihre Fresse so riesen Stickern machen. Vielleicht lasse ich die Plätze aus, wo jemand sitzt. Aber ansonsten, weil die stehen ja auch manchmal auf, gehen ins Boardbistro, gehen aufs Klo oder so und in dem Moment klebe ich das hin und dann.
Und die Frage sich, das war doch gerade, die denken so, da bin ich bescheuert, da war doch nicht dieser riesige Sticker, war doch nicht vorne hier.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das wieder abgeknibbelt werden würde, weil ich meine, in wie vielen verschiedenen ICEs sitze ich denn, wenn ich immer an denselben Tagen zwischen Köln und Hamburg pendle? Das sind wahrscheinlich auch nicht unendlich viele ICEs, vielleicht fünf oder so. Und dann irgendwann habe ich einfach alle fünf ICEs beklebt und es ist einfach normal. Kannst du dir nicht so eine Warnweste anziehen, einfach nur ... Und so eine Leiter auf der Schulter? Die Leiter brauche ich jetzt nicht persönlich. Keine Leiter, so eine Stehleiter. Also ent du dieses dieses namensschild hi my name ist und dann so dieses db machte dir drin db und dann schreibst du den namen hin oder und du bist halt schon in der serviceabteilung diese sticker sind jetzt mandatory oder du bist halt oder ziehst du einfach so eine weisse so eine gelbe warenweste an ich glaube es reicht auch wenn man anzug trägt oder also als offiziell... Genau, ich will nur verhindern, dass du... Wobei, das ist ein Pendler. Ich will nicht, dass es auffällt, dass du so ein ganz normaler Lulli bist, der da mitfährt und dann Leute Sitze beklebt, weil er seine fucking Ruhe haben will, sich dann aber mit Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörern dahinsetzt. Ja, es stimmt. Ja, manchmal sind ja auch so Leute, die dann so Umfragen machen oder so mit so Clipboards oder so, die sehen auch immer nicht so ultraoffiziell aus. Die haben dann glaube ich so einen Anhänger oder so eine Umhänge wie bei so einem Festival. Anhänger. So einen Anhänger, so einen Clip. Muss ich mir alles besorgen, weil ich denke mir, ich glaube, der Aufwand ist vergleichsweise gering. Du investierst halt mal irgendwie 100 Euro in diese 200 Hochglanz-Sticker. Der Aufwand ist gering, der Ertrag ist halt auch sehr gering. Nee, ich glaube, der Ertrag ist enorm. Ich we ist enorm. Weil wie gesagt, es sind ja immer dieselben ICEs, in denen man fährt. Und ich glaube, die meisten Leute würden dann checken, oh, ich sitze im Ruheabteil. Und vielleicht wird das sogar bundesweit eingeführt, weil die Leute das so gut aufnehmen und es so eine gute Idee ist, weil es viele Leute nervt, wenn im Ruheabteil nicht ruhig geblieben wird. Und ich glaube, da kann ich endlich mal anstoßen. Weil ich habe keinen Bock mehr darauf zu warten, bis die Bahn es endlich auf die Reihe kriegt, ihre Ruheabteile durchzusetzen. Schon so oft habe ich gesehen, wie Schaffner vorbeilaufen an Gruppen, wo halt irgendwie Musik gespielt wird aus dem Handy, wo die sich laut unterhalten, offensichtlich im Ruheabteil, kann der nicht mal sagen, Entschuldigung, sitzt im Ruheabteil, setzt nicht doch einfach ein Waggon weiter, da ist alles frei. Und ich habe keinen Bock mehr darauf zu warten, sondern ich nehme das jetzt selber in die Hand. Ich nehme das jetzt selber in die Hand, Ich gehe da hin und klebe die da an, damit da mal was passiert, damit die sich damit, weil wie viel muss passieren, damit es wirklich nach ganz oben geht.
Lassen wir nicht da mal die Schaffner sagen, Herr Bahn, Herr Doktor Rieselkies, da gibt es jemanden, der klebt immer diese Ruheabteilsticker hin, die sind gut gemacht, eigentlich müssten wir die auch nicht wegmachen, weil es ist keine dumme Idee. Also wollen wir das nicht, also ab wann unternehmen die nichts mehr dagegen? Du musst ja schon auch ausdrücken auf Klebepapier, ne? Ja. Also sonst sehe ich dich da mit so einem Tisservilm-Rolle rumlaufen. Ich habe so ganz viele vorgeklebte Streifen an meinem Arm, überall an deinem Gesicht, überall so vorgeklebte Dinger, damit du sehr schnell handeln kannst.
Ja.
Ich finde das extrem spannend und cool, was du davor hast. Ich mach das. Ich seh es nur noch nicht in der Praxis. Ich glaub, du musst halt, es ist halt die Frage, du hast so viel Geld investiert wahrscheinlich, dass es auch so eine Bahnuniform jetzt auch nicht mehr die Welt kosten würde. Und jetzt kommt's. Wer von euch da draußen Lust hat, teilzunehmen, der schickt mir die Adresse und ich schicke euch hundert Sticker. Jetzt sind wir alle zu Kompizen geworden. Ich schicke euch hundert Sticker und ihr klebt die in Ruheabteile, in ICEs, in der ganzen Stadt. Wir machen Stichtag. Oh mein Gott. Ab dem, und ich glaube, das funktioniert, weil, stellt ihr vor, es gibt einen Stichtag, nach dem schlagartig in ganz Deutschland, in allen ICEs, in allen Ruheabteilen diese Sticker kleben. Der normale Bahnmitarbeiter wird das wahrscheinlich gar nicht hinterfragen. Er wird wahrscheinlich annehmen, okay, das wurde jetzt so geändert. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob die über alles informiert werden, was da immer passiert. So, jetzt, ich muss jetzt den Legal Claim noch noch raushauen. Mein Legal-Advice wäre, weil wir jetzt alle Zeugen geworden sind und alle, die jetzt nichts unternehmen, machen sich zu Mittätern dieses Vandalismus-Versuchs. Deswegen mein Vorschlag, schmeißt die Folge aus euren Podcatchern, damit euch nicht nachgewiesen werden kann, dass ihr gehört habt, löschtcht einen Verlauf, damit niemand uns, und ich muss wahrscheinlich ins Ausland, was okay ist, vielleicht kann ich auch ein schönes Ausland. Weil, ne, also ist ja nicht gut, das ist ein Aufruf zum Vandalismus. Nein, was ich brauche, ist, ich brauche einen Designer, der dieses Bild macht, halt irgendwie mit der Bahnfond und so, ich glaube, das ist nicht so aufwendig. Nee, ich glaube auch nicht. Und ein Texter oder sowas, und dann machen wir das. Und dann, glaube ich, wenn du dann einfach so einen grossen, so einen DIN A4-Sticker, was kostet der? Wenn du da einfach 500 Stück kaufst gleichzeitig, kostet es halt vielleicht mal 200 Euro oder so. Du willst einen DIN A4-Sticker. Der muss riesengross sein, der muss richtig gross sein. Die Leute lesen das doch nicht, wenn da so ein Mini-Sticker vor ihnen hängt. Und vor allem dann sieht es nämlich, und weißt du, was richtig geil wäre, wenn der Sticker dieselbe Form hätte wie der obere Teil des Sitzes. Wenn der wirklich massgeschneidert aussieht. Niemand würde denken, das ist Vandalismus. Alle, selbst die Mitarbeiter würden denken, ja, das ist jetzt halt einfach da. Das ändert ja die ganze Lücke eines Waggons, wenn du dann auf jedem Sitz hinten drauf so ein Dina-4-Grosses, halt deine Fresse stehen hast. Ja, es sieht scheiße aus, da gebe ich dir recht. Aber darum geht es ja nicht. Es geht ja darum, dass es ruhig ist. Ich habe doch lieber ein hässliches Abteil, wo ich meine Ruhe habe. Oh, das weiß ich nicht. Da bin ich jetzt gegen. Was heißt gegen. Was heißt hässlich, das muss, vielleicht ist da kein Mensch drauf, weil dann starfst du ständig diesen einen Mensch auf, an der da auf dem Sticker drauf ist. Stockfoodisch Mensch, der nicht wusste, wozu das Bild noch war, der brauchte nur 50 Euro für Stockfood. Und dieses Model sieht sich selbst dann und denkt sich, was, da kann ich mich nicht daran erinnern. Also ich glaube, der Plan ist ausbautfähig, aber wenn das ginge, ich glaube, dann wird es halt richtig teuer, wenn du eine spezielle Form haben willst. Aber so ein rechteckiger Sticker kannst du noch zu Hunderten bestellen irgendwo, schickst du ihnen die Datei, easy.
Aber ich wäre auch noch dafür irgendwie, wenn schon überall auf diesen Sitzen hinten drauf so auf A2-Grösse so ein Poster hängen, dass man die Klappe halten soll, wäre ich dafür, zumindest irgendwie Wortspiele noch zu machen oder so.
Oder so clevere Sprüche.
Ja, Werbetexter sind eingeladen, vielleicht also sowas wie ... Irgendwie so, Beethoven hat nichts gehört und hat die besseren Sachen, die besten Sinfonien geschrieben. Guck mal, sowas. Sowas. Sowas irgendwie, ja, in einem lauten Abteil hätte Einstein seine Relativ-Hessorie auch nicht schreiben können. Ja, finde ich richtig gut. Und sowas, so ein paar lustige Sätzchen, wo alle ein bisschen drüber nachdenken und so. Und dann immer anders vielleicht auch. Nicht, dass auf allen Sitzen hinten so programmatisch dergleiche. Aha, so verschiedene Sprüche, wie so auf den Mülleimern in Berlin, wo du dann so hast, so. Genau. Ja, die Probleme ihrer Freundin interessieren sie, aber den Rest des Abteils nicht. Irgendwie sowas, Auch ein bisschen passiv-aggressiv. Ah ja, finde ich super. So was in der Ecke, so ein paar Flotte sprechen. Niemand interessiert sich für NFTs und Bitcoin. Ja, genau. Ja. Ja. Ich glaube, das geht. Ich glaube, das geht wirklich. Ich bin fest davon überzeugt, dass man sowas verändern kann, weil es nicht Vandalismus ist im Sinne von, ich mache jetzt so lange Ärger, bis ihr macht, was ich will, sondern ich helfe euch direkt. Also anstatt zu verlangen, dass ihr das Problem löst, löse ich das Problem für euch. In eurer Font. In eurer Font und dann müsst ihr nämlich die Entscheidung treffen, es wieder rückgängig zu machen. Und das ist ja, glaube ich, schwieriger, als wenn man einfach sagt, ja, jetzt muss man sich darum kümmern. Weil dann hast du nämlich, dann muss die Bahn nämlich anfangen, hier rumzugehen und alles wegzuknibbeln, was ein Aufwand ist, den sie mir in Rechnung stellen vielleicht, aber ich bin bereit, dieses Opfer zu gehen, weil ich glaube, es ist gut. Aber mir gefällt dieses, weil man nicht mittlerweile alle Typos kriegt man im Internet. Ja. Das heißt, du kannst ja, wir lösen eure Probleme in eurer Font. Genau. Generell auch eine gute Firmenidee für uns. Ja, total!
Hatte Probleme, wir lösen die für euch in eurer Font.
Ja.
Wenn es die bei freefonts.de oder so unterzuladen geht. Ja, ihr habt keinen Bock irgendwie, wir haben eine Charity und wir machen einfach für euch die Font, wir sagen unterstützt von die Bahn, macht ihr selber, wir haben schon eure Font. Es hat mal jemand bei Ikea mit diesen Ikea-Pfeilen auf dem Boden, die die Richtung des Rundweges anzeigen, mit den gleichen Pfeilen einen Irrweg gebaut. Und zwar gibt es in Ikea immer dann diesen Showroom und dann unten, wo es dann zu den Kassen und Ausgang geht. Und da hat jemand mit diesen grossen Pfeilen auf dem Boden, diesen gelben, einen Weg gelegt, der im Kreis führt.
Und Leute haben das nicht gemerkt.
Und da waren Leute in einem Endloskreis gefangen.
Die waren dann, und das war wirklich, die Überschrift war so,
Menschen waren taglang im Ikea, haben den Ausgang nicht gefunden, weil diese Pfeile unten so geil den Weg verlegt haben.
Das gab eine Anzeige.
Und ein bisschen so ist es auch.
Was heißt Anzeige?
Weiß ich nicht.
Welcher Tatbestand denn? Also welches Verbrechen, Irrweg, in die Irre führen? Menschen in die Irre geführt. Menschen verunsichert. Verwirrung. Verwirrung stiften. Es ist nicht erlaubt, andere Menschen zu verwirren. Nee, es ist nach §35 BGB nicht erlaubt, Verwirrung zu stiften und Leute in den Verwirrung abgerunden zu schubsen. Das ist nicht erlaubt. Ja, mal schauen, also falls ihr euch auskennt mit Gesetzen, könnt ihr auch mal sagen, was wäre so die Höchststrafe, die mich ereilen könnte, wie viele Jahre in den Knast könnte ich wandern. Solmecke, falls jemand zuhört, gerne da bitte auch die Komplizenschaft ausweiten auf Rechtsbeistand, damit der mich vertreten muss, falls ich vor Gericht lande. Ja, ich bin noch nicht sicher, ob ich mich jetzt davon distanzieren möchte, weil ich finde, das ist prinzipiell eine gute Idee. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie ich das finden soll, dass alle jetzt große Zettel an Sitze kleben, aber ich bin offen. Okay, und der Termin wurde angek wurde angekündigt für Heizung und Erachtung. Ja, Heizung und Erachtung. Morgen ist es. Morgen rein und du bist jetzt heute im Aufräumstress. Ja, ich bin im Aufräumstress, es ist furchtbar, vor allem, ich plane dann viel zu viel, das ist ja wirklich fast ein ganzes Theaterstück, was ich mir überlege. Wenn der Typ kommt, ich überlege mir, wo sitze ich, was mache ich, während er da ist, was lese ich. Tipp, stell doch einen Koffer irgendwo in den Flur. Das sieht aus, als wärst du selten da oder auf dem Weg. Oder ich packe gerade. Du packst gerade. Es sieht halt so aus, als ob die Unordnung gerechtfertigt sei. Ja, oder so ein Farbeimer. So ein Farbeimer, wo man denkt, ah, der renoviert gerade irgendwie, das ist gerade alles ein bisschen unordentlich. Kauf dir Mehrkram den du in der Wohnung stellen kannst. Sehr gute Idee, finde ich gut. Ja, das ist eigentlich gar nichts. Stell Mehrkram irgendwo rum. Oder einfach so ein Eimerkleister und so eine Rolle Tapete oder so, wo man einfach denkt, ah, okay, der macht gerade was. Das ist alles zu entschuldigen gerade. Ja, oder mach so viel Unordnung, dass man denkt, ah, okay, das ist krankhaft. Ja, das weiß ich nicht, ob das so gut, das ist ja genau das, was ich vermeiden will eigentlich. Nee, aber krankhaftes Messitum ist ja zumindest eine Diagnose. Bei dir ist ja gerade wahrscheinlich einfach nur, oh, was ist ein fauler Idiot. Okay, verstehe. Also eher in die andere Richtung gehen und es noch unordentlicher machen. Der eine und der andere muss ja entscheiden. Entweder musst du aufräumen und es noch unordentlicher machen. Oder halt einfach einen Koffer hinfuhren stellen. Die Koffertakte gefällt mir sehr gut. Fühlt mich auch gut. Gefällt mir richtig gut. Wir erschrecken, wie schnell ich drauf gekommen bin. Weil, ja, wir sind... Ich meine, ich habe jetzt keinen klassischen Koffer, ich reise mit Tasche. Ach Gott. Und deswegen... Ja, ich weiß, ich bin auch kein Fan von dieser Tasche, weil die halt auch irgendwann einfach kaputt geht, wo man einfach weiß, wie viel kann man dem Reisverschluss zumuten. Weil teilweise ist diese Reisetasche so pickepacke vollgepackt für eine Reise und ich denke mir einfach, was hält dieser Reisverschluss aus, wenn der aufgeht, war es das, weil ich habe doppelt so viel Inhalt wie eigentlich in diese Tasche reinpasst. Stehst du da am Bahnsteig, Tasche geht auf, BAP und 500.000 Flugblätter, Sticker, wo draufstehen, Bordrestaurant, hier geht's zum Ausgang im Ikea, lustige, clevere Sprüche, dass man bitte die Fresse halten soll im Bahnabteil, die immer aggressiver werden auch, weil man gemerkt hat, dass du viel zu lange nach diesem Projekt gearbeitet hast, bis plötzlich später die Nacht und dem musst du einfach nur gross Halt dein Maul auf den Zetteln und dann so ganz viel Tesafilm und so Tippex. Und der Täter konnte vor der Tat verhaftet werden. Die werden direkt verhaftet. Warum? Wie haben sie das eingekriegt, den so schnell zu verhaften? Und dem ist die Tasche kaputt gegangen. Der hatte zu viel dabei. Aber der Bahnhof würde sehr leise werden, abrupt sehr leise werden. Ja, das glaube ich auch. Ich glaube, das würde richtig für Aufsehen sorgen, wenn da plötzlich irgendwie 100 Kilometer Tesafilm plötzlich rumfliegen würden. Ich glaube, da guckt man gerne mal hin. Aber wir sind uns ja alle einig, dass zu hohe Lautstärke ja immer unangenehm ist. Leise ist ja immer besser. Ja, egal ob im Kino oder bei der Bahn. Jetzt, wenn man einen Vorschlag, in jeglichen Fonds der Welt zu machen, bitte halt doch bitte dein dummes Maul, in Netta und das hängen wir dann überall auf, auch im Bahnhofsvorraum, auch im Douglas. Ja, ich meine, ein Problem ist natürlich auch, dass natürlich auch bestenfalls Sticker sein müssten, die allgemein verständlich sind, auch wenn man kein Deutsch spricht.
Ja, Englisch und Französisch.
Englisch, Französisch, aber dann ist halt die Frage, wie viele Sprachen braucht man dann, weil wenn du sagst Englisch, Französisch, dann kannst du ja sagen, entweder du machst eine Sprache oder hundert. Nee, halte ich an die Bahnzieher ein. Ja, die hat aber auch noch mehrere Sprachen. Drei Sprachen mit Sicherheit. Nein, nein, nein. Doch Notausgang steht ja nicht in 15 Sprachen. Aber Ruheabteil steht schon in manchen Sprachen, aber halt es wird immer so intransparenter, was auch dumm ist. Je unwichtiger dein Land ist, desto blasser wird es. Und irgendwann kannst du noch... Oh wow, ich habe 30 Prozent Transparenz bekommen, mein Heimatland, Jordanien. Und Eritreisch ist dann nur noch ganz fein, transparent, man muss da ganz nah rangehen. So Kontrast hochdrehen, um es aufzusehen, ja, das stimmt schon. Aber da habe ich mir überlegt, ist es nicht vielleicht klüger, komplett auf Sprache, also auf Buchstaben zu verzichten. Der gute Alte, pssst, ich glaube, Finger vor Mund ist in der gesamten Welt verstanden als sei leise. Vielleicht nicht, vielleicht gibt es auch, weil es gibt ja manchmal, dass Gesten dann was anderes heißt in anderen Ländern. Im Tauchen gibt es das nur. Im Tauchen. Oder halt irgendwie, also vielleicht auch diese Reißverschlussgeste auf den Mund, so dieses Wuh. Das Emoji kannst du einfach nehmen. Das Emoji, ja, das stimmt, mit dem Reissverschluss im Mund, das ist gar nicht schlecht. Ja. Das Emoji, das Psst-Emoji, was gibt's noch vielleicht, dass sich den Mund zuhalten, der Affe, der sich den Mund zuhält. Okay. Sowas in der Richtung, oder dann jemand, der auf seine Ohren so Schmerzen drückt, so Au, Au. Wir machen einfach Bilder mit dir. Bei so einem unnötig künstlerischen Backdrop vor so einem Hintergrund einfach, mit so einem Scheinwerfer, der so in den Hintergrund gerichtet ist und so ein großes Oval zieht. Und vorne ist so ein Barhocker, auf dem du sitzt. So einen schwarzen Overall, mit so einem Turtleneck-Overall, so richtig Künstler-Schauspieler-Fotos. Und ich so eine Hand und einen Mund weit aufgegriffen Kinn in Richtung Decke gestreckt. Und das muss man stundenlang anstarren. Wenn man irgendwie von Hamburg nach München fährt, starrt man mich an, wie ich schmerzverzerrt sehr schlecht gespielt. Ah, ah, meine Ohren zuhalte. Niemand weiß auch genau, wie es gemeint ist. Was heißt das jetzt? Das ist alles, was eine Kunstinstallation ist. Aber jetzt wird es langsam zu diesem, wir verstehen den Arc de Triomphe. Also es wird ja, ja, ja, ja, nee, das wird ein Riesending. Das wird ein Riesending. Wie viele ICEs gibt es in Deutschland? Ja, keine Ahnung. 200? Es sind nicht, ich glaube, es sind nicht unhandhabbar viele. Ich glaube, es ist wirklich machbar. Wenn wir es schaffen, zu einem Stichtat 200 Agenten aus der Podcast-Ufrau-Hörerschaft. Schläfer, Schläfer, Schläfer, Schläfer, Ruheagenten. Was bei uns wirklich oft Schläfer sind, weil viele den Podcast am Einschlafen hören. Ja, das stimmt. Wir nennen sie die Silencer. Deswegen schaut mal vorbei auf silence.com, wo wir uns organisieren. So, wie viele ICs gibt es in Deutschland? Januar 2021 rund 66,9 Millionen in Deutschland zulassende Fahrzeuge. 66 Millionen? Der Fahrzeug bestand. Das ist ein bisschen viel. Wie viele Autos gibt es? Achso, ich habe mich vertan. Hat das nur viele Autos. Autos eingegeben?
Ich habe sehr wenig Blut in meinem Körper, mit dem Gehirn. Vor allem die Finger, aus den Fingern wurde alles abgezogen mittlerweile. Sind ganz kalt. Da geht gar nichts mehr. 315 ICE-Züge befinden sich 2020, wie heißt unser Jahr? 22. 2020, 315 im Jahr 2020 im Bestand der Deutschen Bahn. Im September 2019 wurde bekannt, dass die Fahrzeugplatte der Deutschen Bahn mit der sukzessiven Inbetriebnahme von insgesamt 137 ICE vier Zügen modernisiert wird. Also die laufen die davon. 300, okay. Das geht aber, das geht. Magst du den neuen ICE? Ja, aber ich kriege ihn nicht so oft zu Gesicht. Besschen kantiger wieder, ne?
Ja, ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich auf Strecken fahre, die einfach niedrige Priorität haben und deswegen kriegt man die alten Kisten.
Köln-Hamburg hast ja nur ICs am Start.
Ja, da hast du die ganzen Amülen, da gibt es nicht mal ein Ruheabteil, da kannst du dich nicht mal ärgern.
Das heißt, da müsste man noch mal ganz von vorne ansetzen.
Nee, ich habe eine neue Frage. Sie setzen sich in den Ruheabteil, um sich ärgern zu können? Nein. Da kann man sich nicht immer ärgern, dass wir da sind. Ja, da hat man, ja, weil es ja die eigene Schuld ist. Man kann sich nicht über andere Leute ärgern, weil die ja nichts falsch machen, wenn sie nicht im Ruheabteil sitzen. Okay. Es ist langer, als ob du dich extra in Ruheababteilung setzt, damit du dich einherst. Nein, dann würde ich jetzt gehen. Okay. Und dann ziehe ich meine Schuhe an. Nehmen Sie Ihre volle Tasche mit. Nehmen Sie Ihre zum Bersten gefüllte Tasche mit. Okay, dann hebe ich die Maul. BAP! Ja, das stimmt, aber vielleicht müsste man beim IC noch mal ein Stück vorher ansetzen und da überhaupt erst Ruheabteile beschildern. Also das sind dann zwei Teams, Silence 1, Silence 2, die einen, die überhaupt erstmal Ruheabteile einrichten in ICs und die anderen, die die Ruheabteile in ICs verstärken. Also wir brauchen ein grosses Team, wir brauchen wirklich ein grosses Team. Egal woran ihr arbeitet gerade, lasst es fallen, schickt mir eure Adresse. Also wir können für mehr Ruheabteile sorgen, wenn wir einfach diese Ruheabteilsticker faken und aufhängen in normalen Abteilen? Ich glaube ja, ich glaube, das ist alles möglich. Warum, es gibt Ruheabteile und Handyabteile. Vor allem, Jan, das ist eine Firma, die Deutsche Bahn, aber wer sagt denn, dass man selber da nicht auch mitbestimmen darf ein bisschen, wenn man da das gerne anders hätte? Wir dürfen uns ja nicht einfach so unterbuttern lassen, nur weil ich jetzt halt in einem McDonald's sitze. Nee, ich kann da auch selber mal was aufhängen, ein Bild von mir, das ich gemalt habe. Auch wenn es jetzt nicht da in die Firmenpolitik passt und die halt ja der Chef sind. Ich darf auch da, wir sitzen ja alle dabei und ich darf da auch mal ein bisschen mitmachen. Wir machen ein großes Shooting mit dir, wo du mit diesem schwarzen Rollkragenpulli auch bei McDonalds fasst du so einen Bauch und dein Gesicht sagt, es war Genuss pur und das hängen wir auch ganz gross an. Mit so einer Ampfeltasche, das perfekte Dessert. Da fände ich aus der Hand geraten, diese Aktion. Was soll uns das sagen? Aber das geht ja alles, was einen nervt, kann man ja dann wirklich selber auch ansprechen. Aber jetzt ein Ruheabteil überhaupt erstmal in den Staatsbefällen ist sehr lustig. Ja. Warum hat denn die Bahn entschlossen, dass das Gegenteil von Ruheabteil Handyabteil ist? Ja. Was ist das? Und da brauchen wir auch was, weil ich war in Berlin, als Obama zu Besuch war und da habe ich den Konvoi von Michelle Obama gesehen, der ist an mir vorbeigefahren. Der ist ganz pink und der von Barry ist ganz blau. Ganz hellblau. Und da hat man gemerkt, dass wenn dieser Konvoi kam, 20 Meter bevor der kam, hatte das Handy keinen Empfang mehr. Und dann ist der Konvoi vorbeigefahren, weil da war so ein Berliner Polizist, der gesagt hat, ey, wenn das vorbeifährt, guck mal auf euer Handy. Der war mega, der hat den besten Tag seines Lebens. Weil wenn du dich für sowas interessierst, so Sicherheitskram und so, und so Antiterrorgedöns und so, guckt euch. Und der meint dann, ja, die haben so Jammer in ihren Autos drin, die halt im Umkreis die Handyempfang stören. Wo ich dachte, ja, genau das will ich für ein Ruheabteil haben. Aber warum? Gib mir so ein Ding. Du meinst, damit du keine Bombe zündest. Wahrscheinlich, weil Sprengsätze auch über so Handys gezündet werden. Noch geiler wäre es, wenn die alle mit diesem Handy, polyphone Klingeltöne-Style, so die Nationalhymne spielen würden. Das wäre gut, ja. Alles so kleine Handys, Nokias, die dann so losklirren. Ja, das wäre auch nicht schlecht. Aber sowas, ich meine, wie viel kostet das denn? Ich meine, kann man der Secret Service, wenn die das ausmustern oder so, falls ihr beim Secret Service seid und die mal ausgemustert werden, weil Obama gibt es ja nicht mehr, das sind mir dann halt die schickt einfach an mich. Und ich verstecke die in den Ruheabteilen. Jetzt nähern wir uns in gefährlichen Richtung, aber lass uns im Darknet doch einfach so Handy-Jammer bestellen
und dann verteilen wir die
in unsere Schläferzellen und dann
will ich mal sehen, wie der Rucksack aufgeht
und dann auch noch diese Kabel
und so kleine wie so Kofferbomben
artige Dinge auch noch überall rausfallen,
weil die dann so kleine Jammer
immer noch pro Ruheabteil
befindest so einen Jammer oben. Ja, versteckt man irgendwie. Ich meine, da wird es schon ein bisschen terroristisch. Nee, rum, aber da verlieren wir dich jetzt. Das kann schon sein, dass dann auch das WLAN nicht mehr geht, das wäre halt nicht gut. Da müsste man technisch nochmal genau nachhaken, was das überhaupt ist für ein Gerät. Brauchen die viel Strom oder kann man da einen Akku hinmachen? Machst du schon so einen Akku, so eine 9-Volt-Batterie, damit es noch mehr nach Bombe auch aussieht.
Du musst dann auch noch so Kabel dran befestigen und das so festkleben mit so Panzertape.
Dann hast du diesen Jammer und den klebst du dann so, den musst du dann aber verstecken irgendwo im ICE.
Die Revolution frisst ihre Kinder. Ich habe das Gefühl, das läuft gerade aus dem Ruder.
Und ich bin eigentlich mit guten Intentionen in diese Terrorzelle gekommen.
Ich wollte die Welt verbessern und jetzt nimmt das Ganze so einen ganz anderen Weg gerade an.
Ich disziere mich von meiner eigenen Idee.
Ich möchte damit nichts mehr zu tun haben.
Weißt du, wie es am ruhigsten wäre?
Komplett Stille, wenn du einfach in die Luft sprengst.
Weil die können ja nichts sagen, wenn sie tot sind.
Nee, Flutti, das hören wir mal zu.
Das ist gerade so die Welle 2.0. Wie wir uns langsam, hat die gemerkt, wir uns langsam radikalisieren. Wenn du den ganzen Waggon in die Luft, dann hast du denen mal gezeigt, wo der Hase langläuft. Ja, das stimmt. Spreng die einfach in die Luft. Aber dann gibt es ja Verspätung, das will ich ja auch nicht. Aber vielleicht hast du recht. Ja, du hast recht. Das ist eine gute Idee.
Du hast mich überzeugt.
Wir fassen zusammen. Ihr bestreut euch kleine
Plastikbomben, Kofferbomben
aus dem Darknet und
dann sprengen wir einfach Ruheabteile
in die Luft. Oder alles ausser
die Ruheabteile, dass am Ende
nur noch Ruheabteile da sind und einfach
alle leise sein müssen.
Die Lok auch nicht in die Luft sprengen.
Man kann es neu umkoppeln, oder? Wenn man sich auskennt,
so Guerilla-Koppeln gibt es ja schon ewig.
Das gibt... noch Ruheabteile da sind und einfach alle leise sein müssen. Die Lok auch nicht im Luchtspring. Man kann es neu umkoppeln, oder? Wenn man sich auskennt, so Guerilla- koppeln gibt es ja schon ewig. Dass du die anderen alle abkoppelst und die einfach dann am Bahnhof stehen bleiben. Sind das große Magnete eigentlich, diese Dinger? Diese T-Teile da vorne, diese Dötscher? Ich glaube schon. Das sind riesige Magnete. Magneten? Fliesst da nicht viel Strom rein in die? Wie? Kostet das Strom die Magneten oder muss man die nur einmal aktivieren? Wie funktionieren eigentlich Magneten? Jetzt müssen wir nochmal Folge zwei anhalten von diesem Podcast. Da müssen wir nochmal rein. Ja, oder du hättest uns heute Fragen gemacht. Ach so, ja. Was hast du drei Stunden lang an deinem Handy gemacht? Whirl? Ich war sehr, sehr wenig am Handy, ehrlich gesagt. Whirl ist mittlerweile für mich wie so ein Sport machen, ehrlich gesagt. Das macht man ja einmal am Tag immer nur, oder? Man macht es einmal am Tag und dann mag ich das Wordl und danach denke ich, lege ich das Handy beiseite und lege mich auf die Couch und denke, jetzt habe ich genug getan für heute. Mittlerweile hat es so ein, weil ich rede mir ein, dass es gut für meinen Geist ist und gut für meinen Körper. Ist das das Versprechen, dass man es einmal am Tag macht und dann hat man einen besseren Wortschatz oder was? Einen größeren Wortbeutel? Nö, es ist einfach ein Spiel. Es ist einfach ein Spiel. Aber warum warum darf man es nur einmal am Tag machen? Die Seite hat nur ein Rätsel pro Tag, alle haben das gleiche Rätsel pro Tag. Ach so, wie so ein Kreuzworträtsel. Genau. Und alle machen dasselbe? Alle machen dasselbe Rätsel pro Tag. Deswegen ist es ja so spannend, die Ergebnisse zu teilen. Ah, okay, langsam verstehe ich's. Zu langsam würde ich behaupten, weil es sehr einfach ist, das Spielkonzept auch. Wir müssen fünf Wörter, Buchstaben, beworten.
Fünf Buchstaben.
Fünf Buchstaben gibt's, okay.
Nur sechs Versuche Zeit, darauf zu kommen.
Aber das könnte auch alles derselbe Buchstabe sein.
Das ist aber kein Wort.
Aha.
Aber jetzt sowas wie ba, ba, ba?
Kein Wort.
Kein Wort, okay. Banana, aber keine fünf Buchstaben. Und sowas wie Affe Ausrufezeichen ging nicht. Ging jetzt nicht. Okay. Ja, ich habe noch ein paar Fragen. Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen zu Wordle. Fucking Wordle. Ich habe noch ein paar Fragen. Aber da kam, also, gibt es denn die Möglichkeit, darüber geheime Botschaften zu senden an die Welt? Weil da gibt es jetzt irgendeinen Entwickler, der hat ja wahrscheinlich nicht damit gerechnet, dass World jetzt dieses riesige Erfolg wird. Und der sucht ja aus, welche Wörter die Lösung sind. Ja, vor allem ist er Multimillionär geworden. Und es ist nicht so, dass es irgendwie Werbung hätte, diese Seite. Es ist einfach eine Seite, wo jeden Tag ein Rätsel drauf ist, mit fünf Buchstaben und du musst das Wort erraten. So ein lüsches kleines Rätsel. Wieso ist er jetzt Millionär? Ja, das geht dann ganz schnell plötzlich schnell plötzlich. Nee, wie, aber wieso? Why? Warum bist du plötzlich dann direkt Millionär? Vielleicht hat er das verkauft? Nee, aber die New York Times hat das doch gekauft, oder? Kann das nicht sein? Ich habe da irgendwas gehört, die New York Times kauft... Ich verstehe es nicht. Einfach so, du hast eine Idee, die nicht rentabel ist, stellst du das Internet, alle benutzen das und du bist... Wie wirst du denn automatisch... Kriegst du dann so einen Brief, wie so Hogwarts Einladung, wir sind jetzt Millionär.
Einfach Cash.
Welt dankt ihnen für eine schöne Idee. Cash. Mich aber eigentlich nicht schlecht. Genau, eine Million, aufs Mal, genau. Ja, komisch. Aber ich meine, du könntest ja sagen, jetzt klar, wie sähe eine gute Botschaft in fünf Wörtern aus? Ruhig, leise,
still,
ach so, bei mir war es stille,
Krieg, jetzt.
Aber welches Land
hat fünf Buchstaben?
Kamer,
Un,
Krieg,
jetzt, Litauen,
China. China. Okay. Krieg jetzt Litauen China China okay Leute fucking Wordle erzeugt den dritten Weltkrieg Wordle hat den dritten Weltkrieg ausgelöst aber diese Websites werden schon teilweise sehr
übergrifflich Duolingo ist mittlerweile extrem hart. Ja? Ich habe jetzt aufgehört, Spanisch zu lernen,
und es kommen täglich E-Mails,
wo es heißt,
du hast Duo traurig gemacht.
Und dann kommt dann diese Eule, die weint,
tote Augen inzwischen,
weint. Wenn du heute deine Vokabeln nicht machst,
erschießen wir zwei Geistern.
Ja. Aber Duolingo, was ist denn hier?
Duolingo ist crazy am Start.
Das ist psychopathisch. Guck, was du Duo angetan hast, so ein Video, so ein verpixeltes Rotten.com-Video, wo so eine Eule, so eine Eule mit so Medikamente nimmt und so Augenringe hat. Schau mal, was du so einem angetan hast. Gestern war es uns dann so ein Video, so eine Spycam auf so einer Zelle, wo einfach so eine Eule festgeschnallt wurde und so ein Wassertropfen immer auf sich drauf. Das war extrem, weil ich kein Spanisch mehr lerne. Ja. Und es ist auch nicht so, dass ich Duolingo Plus hatte oder sowas. Nee, das ist die normale Variante, die haben dich sofort drin. Die ganz normale Duolingo. Die haben dich sofort drin. Das war knallhart. Einfach so diese Eule, wie sie so langsam auf so ein rotierendes Sägeblatt zufährt, einfach so. Du hast noch drei Stunden und vierzig Vokabeln. Aber es ist so fucking emotionaler Erpressung. Es ist wie so eine ungesunde Beziehung, aus einer ungesunden Beziehung raus zu sein. Und sie schreibt dann noch ab und zu. Und man denkt immer so, hey, komm, es ist wirklich vorbei, und es ist besser und so. Und jetzt so jedes Tag kommt so, was ist los, warum willst du dich nur noch melden, warum übst du nicht mal mit mir Vokabeln, was ist jetzt los? Also ich verstehe, bei dir ist es mittlerweile ein Widerstandsakt, dass du gerade nicht Vokabeln lernst, weil du sagen willst, nein, das muss aufhören, wir haben uns auseinandergelebt. Also wenn Duo das so mitnimmt, dass ich jetzt eine Woche Spanisch geübt habe und dann nicht mehr, habe ich das Gefühl, dann ist es besser, wenn wir Abstand haben. Ja, ich verstehe schon. Du würdest die falschen Signale senden, wenn du jetzt dann doch wieder Vokabeln lernen würdest. Genau, du musst jetzt mal lernen, dass es einfach aussieht. Ja, genau. Und da musst du auch hart bleiben.
Du hast dich da was reingesteigt.
Da musst du hart bleiben. Egal, wie sehr du jetzt Vokabeln lernen willst, wie sehr du irgendwie Narcos im Original schauen würdest, du musst jetzt hart bleiben, Stefan.
Aber was mich ein bisschen schlecht ist, ich habe von Anfang an klar gemacht, hey, ich probiere das hier mal aus.
Du warst ehrlich von der ersten Sekunde an, das fand ich gut.
Ich möchte mich nicht noch reinlassen vielleicht. Ich bin Playboy, ich gehe ab und zu in meine Apps rein, gucke mal, ob die mir gefallen. Wenn du eine Eule siehst, dann bist du auch nur ein Mensch. Ey, und ich bin auch noch bei Babbel angemeldet. Du hast die Eule aber wusste, wusste sie halt auch. Wusste alles. Sie hat ja die App gesehen. Wusste sie alles, Babbel wusste es nicht, aber du wusste, dass ich auch was mit Babbel am Start habe. Klar, du hast von Anfang an mit offenen Karten gespielt. Aber jetzt dann so Mails zu schreiben, so von wegen, hey, was ist da los, warum kommst du nicht mehr, fand ich jetzt auch schwierig. Du wusste, was passiert. Du bist ja auf einem völlig richtigen Weg, du machst das genau richtig und ich finde es gut, dass du dein Spanisch dafür aufgegeben hast, eine Botschaft zu zeigen. Leute, vielleicht war das die letzte Folge, wenn ich nächste Woche im Gefängnis sitze für Kleberterrorismus. Ansonsten, der erste Schritt muss jetzt sein, wir müssen diesen Sticker designen. Also, falls ihr Grafiker, Illustrator, Fotograf seid, der dir Fotos machen könnte. Wollen wir uns auf Reddit eigentlich treffen? Vernetzen? Ich glaube, das ist gesichert. Wollen wir uns ungesund auf reddit.com slash r slash
podcast
das podcast ufo. Ich glaube, Reddit ist
verschlüsselt. Ich glaube, da können wir unsere Zelle gründen.
Also kommt da vorbei, wenn ihr
Bock habt auf Aktionen, auf Revolutionen,
mal was in die Hand zu nehmen, mal die Welt zum Besseren zu
verändern, okay? Dann treffen wir uns da.
Ansonsten haut rein, habt eine schöne Woche.
Und wir heben
ab!